hey youtubers is Charlie my spidey
senses tingling so we learned about some
other vendors that might be popping up
in spider-man homecoming like his friend
from Brooklyn and we learned about when
the first trailer might be dropping so
here we go so we all know that Robert
Downey jr. has been confirmed for
spider-man homecoming you know he's
gonna be used in a small way but
important I'm not expecting him to have
as much time on screen as they'd like
spider-man had during Civil War like
it's gonna be a spider-man movie so it's
mostly gonna be spider-man interacting
with those characters Avengers will just
be cameo II but it makes sense that they
would follow up on the energy of that
like spider-man interaction with Captain
America during civil war where he comes
into the fight as Iron Man's new ringer
but he's also this huge fan and looks up
to Captain America hey cap big fan so it
would make sense that that you know if
they're not gonna do the Uncle Ben
origin story that they would still
maintain the great power great
responsibilities subtext of the
spider-man character and just passed
that on to Iron Man and Captain America
the real question though is because
Captain America is now off the grid he's
still a fugitive from the government so
he has to stay on the DL but I think the
end tag for civil war was a sign that
the really bad blood like that I want to
shoot you in the face bad blood between
Captain America and Iron Man is largely
gone but I'm not expecting a scene where
they interact together on screen I'm
just expecting scenes where Spiderman
interacts with Iron Man and then
separately in other scenes he interacts
with Captain America but in that there
will be some connective tissue to the
stuff that happened with all those
characters in Civil War
now remember Captain America left the
shield behind he's not Captain America
anymore so I don't think that spider-man
is gonna give him his shield back even
though that happened during civil war in
the comics that's just because the
Russos have said that when Avengers
infinity war picks back up he won't be
the Captain America character he'll just
be Steve Rogers like the Captain America
name is dead for all intents and
purposes it's like it's sitting on a
shelf somewhere waiting for someone to
pick it up or Steve Rogers to pick it
back up but because they're kind of like
the moral conscience of spider-man right
now like he looks up to them so they're
meant to be these big role models even
though they took a few knocks during
Civil War like morally they were on
shaky ground for a little bit of it like
Steve Rogers not letting Tony Stark know
that Winter Soldier killed his
even though he knew beforehand but even
though each of them kind of giving
spider-man some advice like being the
big brother or the father figure that he
doesn't have right now is a really cool
idea I do expect them to have like some
cool moment they'll be the all moment
like oh that's you know really awesome
speech they gave to him they gave him
some help in making some big decision
that he needed to make but they'll also
probably be oh my god that's cool a
moment like the thing with Tony Stark is
that he always has the best toys but
Captain America has all the amazing
moves but just expect spider-man to have
a little bit of fun with his friend from
Brooklyn like he told Aunt May oh was
your friend from oh he's from Brooklyn
you know met a guy he's from Brooklyn
and his other friend Tony Stark who Aunt
May already knows about but the other
rumor now is that Black Widow will also
have a small role in the film so
wouldn't it be fun if they use those
three Avengers characters is a form of
spider-man's it super-ego and ego so
Freudian psychology the it is kind of
like Tony Stark the instinctual part of
your brain that acts on impulse the
super-ego is the moralizing part of your
brain the Captain America part the part
of your brain that's always telling you
to do what's morally right in each
situation and then the ego is kind of
like the Black Widow the thing that
mediates between the desires of the it'd
in the super-ego so you have Iron Man
who just is very impulsive you have
Captain America that's always taken the
moral high ground then you have Black
Widow who tries to like mediate between
the two of them like dudes do not fight
let's be reasonable about this so maybe
they'll end up using those characters in
the spider-man movie in that way like
spider-man has a lot of problems that he
faces he has things that he wants to do
he has things that he knows he should
probably do and he needs to find some
sort of compromise between them but let
me know in the comments how do you think
they would use Captain America in Black
Widow
in a spider-man movie now we kind of
know Iron Man is giving him technology
like on a very simple level he's just
giving him some upgrades giving him a
little bit of advice maybe some help
with the big villain with the vulture in
the film but on a much deeper subtextual
level I think they'll feel like the it
ego super-ego in the great power a great
responsibility theme to the Spider Man
character but you know very important
for the spider-man character but since
they're not going to do the Uncle Ben
origin story they're not litter
going to do that scene again so they
have to weave it into the subtext of the
film but for those you asking there is a
rumor that a Spider Man trailer is gonna
drop in the middle of October it son
confirmed but supposedly there was like
a leak that listed like when a bunch of
trailers were gonna be released there
was a Spider Man trailer listed smack
dab in the middle of October so just be
prepared for your spidey sense to start
tingling and if you guys didn't know
there is a new round of the giveaway
that's going on now the Civil War
blu-rays coming out on Friday all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video it's
just for the value of the blu-ray so
it's about a thirty dollar Amazon gift
card so get hype they just announced a
really big cast member Jim Broadbent is
joining Game of Thrones season seven I
have a couple of theories about who I
think he's gonna be so I'll be doing a
video for that later tonight I also
still want to do that Justice League
Deathstroke follow-up video Joe
Manganiello rumored to be playing
Deathstroke but it's unconfirmed there
are a couple other big actors that I
think could pull it off so try to get
that stuff out as fast as possible while
you guys wait for that to post you can
click here to watch the Civil War
bloopers again and you can click here
for spider-man homecoming behind the
scenes thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys time